i'll tell you one of the aspects of your
book that i found
unsettling let's say i i've had this
experience
i think i've talked about it before on
another podcast perhaps at the bernardo
castro if you've heard of him
where it was the middle of the night i'd
woken up from a dream
and then as i was falling back to sleep
in this
hypnagogic state i heard
my wife say a word i don't know what
she's i don't know
i don't i still don't know she said or
didn't say but it could have been it
doesn't actually matter it was like yes
or okay
and then i wasn't sure if she had
actually said it
and i started to go into a spiral
of extreme anxiety and i'm not a person
who's ever had a panic attack in my life
but then i started to feel like am i
going crazy
am i am i hearing voices i don't want to
hear voices
oh my gosh and then i started to think
okay don't hear a voice don't hear voice
but then i was thinking about freudian
repression am i now repressing a voice
that will come back even harder later
oh no so should i move toward a voice
what would what if the voice tells me to
kill myself i'm not suicidal i don't
hate my life not in the least what if it
tells me to harm someone else
and and then i i had to wake my wife up
and tell her
please help me because i'm i'm i i'm i
need help breathing
and then so she called me through that
the next day i had a similar panic
attack
and then two days later had half of one
then it just went away i even talked to
my doctor about this she said you should
go to psychotherapy to talk
talk this out but it it ameliorated on
its own
then a couple days ago this is fresh but
this came from your
book this is why i i love you but then i
curse you at the same time
there's plenty of talk in your book
about schizophrenia and each time that
would come up my heart would race
and i'm hearing myself in it where
i'm not the type of person that as you
know if i'm talking to you i'm not a
a fundamentalist materialist who
dispenses with the divine and so on in
fact i'm extremely open to it
and the eulogisms i get for this channel
is that i'm extremely open and
actually trying to understand like i'm
trying to understand your point of view
i'm trying to morph it
with mine i'm trying to understand other
people's but that's extremely
difficult because it puts me on such
unstable ground
that i don't know what's real and then
i'm constantly questioning what's real
is this real
am i the only one that's real my fake is
are people lying to me and
and sometimes just when i say it out
loud it
it helps me through it part of it is
like i'm keeping it in and i don't want
to scare my spouse i don't want to scare
someone else
but i also thought another part is that
there's no one else that i hear talk
about this much not no one in the public
sphere
and so i thought one time i heard
peterson was schizophrenic it was
turns out to be false but that actually
gave me gave me hope because i was like
oh my gosh someone else is experiencing
this
and then i thought okay kurt why don't
you talk about it first of all it's
curative to myself
second of all someone else might hear it
and be like okay this is
i'm not someone who's asinine and and so
maybe someone else who's somewhat normal
is going through this castrop said kurt
don't worry
this is part of the spiritual journey
when you question consciousness and you
involve yourself in these subjects this
will happen
but either way what you said which is
that you view the world more and more
mechanistically that's the left brain
now that's my entire life up until maybe
a few years ago
because i'm trained as a physicist a
scientist
and that and that you're extremely
speaking to yourself over and over and
over and i feel like that's what i do
and i've estrude music too
for the past 12 years i haven't listened
to music because i just find it to be a
time waster
and i'm wondering how much have i hurt
myself by doing so
i wanted to say this to you because well
first i just want to hear your thoughts
and then you can also relate it to the
world at large yes
well um i think it's not unusual for
people to
to have these experiences and
people who think a lot ponder a lot
philosophize a lot conceptualize a lot
do come to this crisis of doubt if you
like and it's
i mean the first great exponent of this
was descartes
um but
for his age he lived remarkably
ungrounded kind of existence what i mean
is that most people then still
lived a more rooted embodied existence
and he probably
by his personality as much as anything
was inclined
to i think he had a schizoid temperament
actually
and why this is important is that
there's a wonderful book which i
often mentioned and we'll mention again
by louis sass a psychologist at rutgers
called
madness and modernism and it is a
fascinating
work and
it was completely another of these sort
of eureka moments for me when i read it
because he drew so many parallels
between schizophrenia
and modern culture
i mean even including high culture and
he drew
25 or 30 parallels that are clear to
anyone
like him or me who has treated many
patients with schizophrenia
between the way they encounter things
experience them and aspects of modernity
and this comes together for me in the
fact that the left hemisphere is in a
way
ungrounded it has taken things taken
them out of context
taking them out of the lived experience
of the body
just detached them from what they mean
to us
and then said i don't know what this
means because
as it were having taken it out ripped it
out of the context it would give it
meaning
it no longer has any meaning this
induces a sort of what's real what isn't
real
now only people who live the sort of
very strange life that we do
are likely to be tormented by this
because they don't see consciousness as
something in here
and a reality that's just out there we
come back to something
we talked about a little earlier and
could talk about a lot more
which is how are you see two things
later co-creating it's neither that
there's just an in here and an out there
nor that it's all made up or it's you
know
so it's a it's a connection
we are beings that can
attend to the world that is our essence
and as louis lavelle 20th century
philosopher said attention is love love
is a pure attention to the existence of
whatever
is other another person another thing
and i think that that
is how we relate to the world that it is
not
it's not alien to us at all nor are we
alien to it it's not that we have to
figure it out
as if it were an odd thing that had
dropped in our past you know
um paley in his um
deism thought that it gave the image
that the universe was like a watch that
some
sorry paley an 18th century bishop
yes yes thomas paley i think he was and
said that
um you know imagine the world is like
a watch you walk on a heath you find
this watch
you immediately know there must be a
watchmaker i mean this thing didn't just
happen
so he says the world is like this and
dawkins
says and i think very fairly that he is
himself
a paleous without god because he just
like paley thinks there is a mechanism
here that is working itself out
he just doesn't think it's god he thinks
it's genetics that there is something as
it were
in a gene the robot that
controls et cetera these images of
control
are there in him as they would be in the
idea of a deistic god
i what i mean by a deity god is a an
engineering god
an engineer who is separate from
creation winds it up and
occasionally tinkers with it whereas i
believe whatever is divine is in the
fabric
of the world and is not known not
certainly even to whatever that divinity
is
it's a process of true creation sort of
exhilaration of that that carries the
whole process
of creation of a creative cosmos anyway
i'm i'm probably not making sense it's
so hard to convey these things briefly
but
shelling in the 18th century was one of
my favorite um
philosophers was able to express this
not not very easy german i have to agree
but this is at the core of his
perception that
the inner and the outer as is often said
in
many non-western cultures they are
distinct
but they're not separate and that's a
very important point
that it comes back again to the business
of not being lost
in um a context you're distinct
from another person but you're not
separate from them or sort of divided
from them
you're connected to them but you're
still distinct
and i sort of think of the world as
being seamless
but with you can go seamlessly
from um red to green without
even knowing that this has happened you
know in in a three or four minute film
the color can change nobody notices the
color changing but it's changed
completely
so it's possible to move along a
continuum and
and the spectrum of colors is an example
of something that is not a concatenation
it's not lots of little separate colors
it is
simply a spectrum that can be moved
along
in such a way that you can go from
something very
distinct to something else distinct but
they're never been separate they've
never been
cut off from one another they're part of
the same
whole and i think that a number of
physicists that i've
read in my attempts to understand modern
um well quantum field theory actually is
the theory that
i find most congenial to my philosophy
and seems to be being espoused by a lot
of
physicists but in that case again
things can be distinct but not
ultimately separate they
they belong to fields which can be more
concentrated or collapsed in certain
ways at certain times in certain places